Comme beaucoup d'entre vous ici, j'essaie de contribuer
à une renaissance de l'Afrique.
La question de la transformation en Afrique
est vraiment une question de leadership.
L'Afrique ne peut être transformée que par des leaders éclairés.
Et je suis certain que la manière avec laquelle
nous éduquons nos leaders est fondamentale
pour progresser sur ce continent.
Je veux vous raconter quelques histoires qui illustrent mon point de vue.
Nous avons tous compris, hier, l'importance des histoires.
Une amie Américaine, cette année, s'est portée infirmière volontaire au Ghana.
En trois mois, elle est arrivé à une conclusion
à propos du leadership en Afrique
qu'il m'avait fallut dix ans à comprendre.
A deux reprises, alors qu'elle participait à des opérations chirurgicales,
ils ont perdu le courant à l'hopital.
Les générateurs d'urgence n'ont pas démarré
il n'y avait pas de lampes de poche, pas une lanterne, pas une bougie.
Noir total.
Le patient est grand ouvert -- les deux fois.
La première fois c'était une césarienne.
Heureusement, le bébé était sorti -- la mère et l'enfant ont survécu.
La deuxième fois c'était pendant une opération avec anesthésie locale.
Les anesthésiques disparaissent. Le patient sent la douleur.
Il pleure. Il hurle. Il prie.
Noir total. Pas une bougie, pas une lampe de poche.
Et cet hôpital avait les moyens d'avoir des lampes de poches.
Ils auraient pu se permettre d'en acheter, mais ils ne l'ont pas fait.
Et c'est arrivé à deux reprises.
Une autre fois, elle a vu avec horreur un patient mourir
parce qu'ils refusaient de lui donner l'oxygène qu'ils avaient.
Et donc, trois mois plus tard,
juste avant qu'elle revienne aux Etats-Unis,
les infirmières d'Accra se sont mises en grève.
Et sa recommandation était
de saisir cette opportunité pour renvoyer tout le monde, et tout recommencer à nouveau.
Tout recommencer à nouveau.
Qu'est-ce que tout cela à avoir avec le leadership?
Voyez-vous, les fautes du ministère de la santé,
des administrateurs d'hopitâl, des médecins, des infirmières --
ils ne sont que 5% de leurs pairs
à avoir continué les études après le lycée.
Ils sont l'élite. Ils sont nos leaders.
Leurs décisions, leurs actes sont importants.
Et quand ils échouent, une nation, littéralement, souffre.
Et quand je parle de leadership,
je ne parle pas seulement des leaders politiques.
On a déjà beaucoup entendu parler de ça.
Je parle de l'élite
Ceux qui ont été formés.
Et dont le travail est d'être les gardiens de leur société.
Les avocats, les juges, les policiers, les médecins,
les ingénieurs, les fonctionnaires --
ceux-là sont les leaders.
Et nous devons les former correctement.
Ma première expérience notable avec le leadership au Ghana
a eu lieu quand j'avais 16 ans.
Nous venions de subir un putsch militaire,
et les soldats étaient omniprésents dans notre société.
Ils étaient partout.
Et un jour, en allant à l'aéroport pour retrouver mon père,
alors que je marche sur cette pente herbeuse qui va du parking
jusqu'au bâtiment du terminal,
je suis arrêté par deux soldats brandissant des fusils d'assauts AK-47.
Ils m'ont ordonné de rejoindre une foule de gens
qui tournaient en rond un peu plus loin.
Pourquoi ? Parce que le chemin que j'avais pris était considéré comme interdit.
Rien ne l'indiquait.
J'avais 16 ans. J'étais très préoccupé
par ce que mes camarades d'école pourrait penser
si ils me voyaient tourner en rond sur cette colline.
J'étais particulièrement préoccupé par ce que les filles pourraient penser.
Alors j'ai commencé à discuter avec ces hommes.
J'étais un peu imprudent mais, vous savez, j'avais 16 ans.
J'ai eu de la chance.
Un pilote de Ghana Airways s'est retrouvé dans la même situation.
A cause de son uniforme, ils lui parlent différemment,
et ils lui expliquent qu'ils ne font que suivre les ordres.
Alors il prend leur radio, parle à leur chef
et nous fait tous libérer.
Quelles leçons tireriez-vous d'une telle expérience ?
Plusieurs, quant à moi.
Le leadership est important. Ces hommes suivent
les ordres d'un officier supérieur.
J'ai appris quelque chose sur le courage.
Il était important de ne pas regarder les armes.
Et j'ai aussi appris qu'il peut être utile de penser aux filles.
(Rires)
Quelques années après cet évènement, j'ai quitté le Ghana avec une bourse
pour aller étudier au Swarthmore College.
Ce fut une grande bouffée d'oxygène.
Dans cette université là, ils ne voulaient pas que nous mémorisions l'information
pour leur répéter, comme j'en avais l'habitude au Ghana.
Ils voulaient que nous pensions de manière critique.
Que nous soyons capables d'analyser.
Ils voulaient que nous soyons concernés par les problèmes sociaux.
Dans mes cours d'économie, j'ai obtenu de bonnes notes
pour ma compréhension des principes économique de base.
Mais j'ai appris quelque chose de plus profond que ça,
c'est que les leaders -- les administrateurs de l'économie du Ghana --
prenaient des décisions incroyablement mauvaises
qui ont amené notre système au bord de l'effondrement.
Et donc, voici encore cette leçon -- le leadership est important.
Il importe énormément.
Mais je n'avais pas tout à fait compris ce qui m'était arrivé à Swarthmore.
J'avais juste une intuition.
Mais je l'ai vraiment réalisé quand je suis arrivé sur le marché du travail
et que je suis allé travailler à Microsoft.
Je faisais alors partie de cette équipe -- cette équipe qui pense et réfléchit,
et dont le travail était de concevoir des nouveaux logiciels
qui créent de la valeur à travers le monde.
Et c'était brillant de faire partie de cette équipe.
C'était brillant.
Et j'ai alors réalisé ce qui m'était arrivé à Swarthmore,
cette transformation --
cette capacité à confronter les problèmes, les problèmes complexes,
et à concevoir des solutions pour ces problèmes.
La capacité de créer est la chose la plus gratifiante
qui puisse arriver à un individu.
Et j'en faisais partie.
Pendant que j'étais à Microsoft, les revenus annuels de cette compagnie
ont dépassé le PIB de la République du Ghana.
Et d'ailleurs, ils continuent d'augmenter.
L'écart s'est élargi depuis que je suis parti.
J'ai déjà parlé des raisons pour lesquelles cela est arrivé.
C'est que les gens là-bas travaillent si intensément,
ils sont persistants, créatifs, investis.
Mais il y avait aussi des facteurs externes :
libres marché, droit, infrastructures
Tout cela était apporté par des institutions
dirigés par ces gens que j'appelle les leaders.
Et ces leaders ne sont pas apparus spontanément.
Quelqu'un les a formés à faire le travail qu'ils font.
Pendant que j'étais à Microsoft, cette drôle de chose est arrivée.
je suis devenu père.
Et pour la première fois, l'Afrique a compté pour moi plus que jamais.
Parce que j'ai compris que l'état du continent africain
serait important pour mes enfants et leurs enfants.
Que l'état du monde -- l'état du monde
dépend de ce qui se passe avec l'Afrique,
et que mes enfants seraient concernés.
Et à cette époque, alors que je traversais
ce que j'appelle ma "crise de milieu de vie",
l'Afrique était en pagaille.
La Somalie s'était dissoute dans l'anarchie.
Le Rwanda était dans les souffrances du génocide.
Et il m'a semblé que cétait la mauvaise direction,
et que j'avais besoin de revenir pour aider.
Je ne pouvais pas juste rester à Seattle et y élever mes enfants
dans un quartier aisé et me sentir bien comme ça.
Ce n'était pas le monde dans lequel je voulais voir mes enfants grandir.
Alors j'ai décidé de m'engager, et la première chose que j'ai faite
a été de retourner au Ghana et parler avec beaucoup de gens
et essayer de comprendre ce qu'étaient les vrais problèmes.
Et trois causes revenait sans cesse pour chaque problème :
corruption, institutions faibles
et les personnes qui les dirigent -- les leaders
J'étais un peu effrayé
parce que, quand vous voyez ces trois problèmes
ils semblent vraiment durs à résoudre.
Et on pourrait se dire : n'essaie même pas.
Mais, pour moi, la question était :
Mais d'où viennent ces leaders ?
Comment se fait-il que le Ghana produise des leaders
malhonnêtes et incapables de résoudre les problèmes ?
Je suis donc allé voir ce qui se passait dans notre système d'éducation.
Et c'était la même chose-- l'apprentissage par coeur --
de l'école primaire aux études supérieures.
L'accent était très peu mis sur l'éthique.
Et un étudiant lambda, un diplômé typique
d'une université au Ghana a un sens plus fort
de ses propres droits que de ses responsabilités.
Ce n'est pas bien.
J'ai décidé de me confronter à ce problème en particulier.
Parce qu'il me semble que chaque société, chaque société,
doit être très attentive dans sa manière de former ses dirigeants.
Et le Ghana ne faisait pas assez attention.
Et cela est vrai à travers tout l'Afrique sub-saharienne.
Donc voilà ce que je fais maintenant.
J'essaie d'apporter en Afrique ce que j'ai appris à Swarthmore.
Je souhaite qu'il y ait une université d'arts libéraux dans chaque pays d'Afrique.
Je pense que cela ferait une grande différence.
Et ce que l'Université d'Ashesi essaie de faire
est de former une nouvelle génération de leaders honnêtes et entreprenants.
Nous essayons de former des dirigeants d'une intégrité exceptionnelle,
qui ont la capacité de se confronter à des problèmes complexes,
de poser les bonnes questions et d'arriver avec des solutions réalisables.
J'avoue qu'il y a des fois où cela ressemble à "Mission Impossible".
Mais nous devons croire en l'intelligence de ces jeunes.
Que si on s'implique dans leur éducation,
si on les fait discuter des vrais problèmes auxquels ils se confrontent,
auxquels la société entière se confronte --
et si nous leurs donnons les compétences qui leur permettent de se mesurer au monde,
alors la magie arrivera.
Un mois après le début du projet, nous venions de commencer les cours.
Et un mois après, j'arrive à mon bureau,
et je tombe sur un email de l'un de nos étudiants.
Et il disait, très simplement, "Maintenant, je pense".
Et il signe "Merci".
C'est une déclaration tellement simple.
Mais j'en étais ému presque jusqu'aux larmes
parce que j'avais compris ce qui était entrain d'arriver à ce jeune homme.
Et c'est une chose fabuleuse
d'aider quelqu'un comme cela.
Maintenant, je pense.
Cette année-là, nous avions mis au défi nos étudiants
de créer eux-mêmes un code d'honneur.
II y a un très vif débat en ce moment au sein de l'université,
pour savoir s'il devrait y avoir un code d'honneur,
et si oui, à quoi il devrait ressembler.
Une étudiante a posé une question qui m'a fait chaud au coeur.
Peut-on créer une société parfaite ?
Le fait d'avoir compris qu'un code d'honneur écrit par des étudiants
puisse être un chemin vers la perfection est incroyable.
Bien sûr, on ne peut pas atteindre la perfection.
Mais si on tend vers elle, on peut atteindre l'excellence.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'ils vont faire au bout du compte.
Je ne sais pas s'ils décideront d'avoir ce code d'honneur.
Mais le débat qu'ils ont en ce moment --
sur ce à quoi leur belle société devrait ressembler,
ce à quoi leur excellente société devrait ressembler --
est une très bonne chose.
Je n'ai plus de temps ? OK.
Voilà, je veux laisser cette diapo
parce qu'il est important qu'on y pense.
Je suis très excité par le fait
que chaque étudiant rendent des services à la communauté avant d'être diplômé.
Pour beaucoup d'entre eux, cela a été une forte expérience de vie.
Ces jeunes futures leaders commencent à comprendre
ce qu'est vraiment le leadership
Le vrai apanage du leadership,
qui est, après tout, de servir l'humanité.
Je suis encore plus enchanté par le fait que l'année dernière
notre corps étudiant a élu une femme
pour être à la tête de notre Conseil Etudiant.
C'est la première fois dans l'histoire du Ghana
qu'une femme a été élue à la tête d'un Conseil Etudiant
dans une université.
Cela en dit beaucoup à propos d'elle.
Cela en dit beaucoup sur la culture qui se forme dans le campus.
Cela en dit beaucoup sur ses camarades qui l'ont élu.
Elle a gagné avec 75 % des votes.
Et cela me donne beaucoup d'espoir.
Il s'avère que les entreprises d'Afrique de l'Ouest
apprécie également ce qui se passe avec nos étudiants.
Nous avons diplômé deux classes d'étudiants à ce jour.
Et chacun d'entre eux a trouvé un emploi.
Et nous avons de très bons retours
des entreprises Ghanéennes et d'Afrique de l'Ouest.
Et ce qui les impressionnent le plus c'est à propos du travail éthique.
Vous savez, cette passion pour ce qu'ils font.
Cette persistance, cette capacité à traiter avec ce qui est ambigu,
cette capacité à s'attaquer à des problèmes nouveaux.
Cela est bien parce que, voyez-vous,
pendant ces cinq dernières années, il y a des fois
où je me disais c'est "Mission Impossible".
Et il est merveilleux de voir ces lueurs
de promesses de ce qui peut arriver si nous formons bien nos enfants.
Je crois que les les actuels et futurs leaders de l'Afrique
ont cette incroyable opportunité
de mener une renaissance majeure sur le continent.
C'est une opportunité incroyable.
Il n'y a plus beaucoup d'opportunités ce genre dans le monde.
Je crois que l'Afrique a atteint un point d'inflexion
avec des avancées démocratiques et des libres marchés à travers le continent.
Nous avons atteint un moment à partir duquel peut émerger
une société formidable en moins d'une génération
Cela repose sur un leardership éclairé.
Et je suis certain que la manière avec laquelle nous formons nos leaders
fera toute la différence.
Merci, et Dieu vous bénisse.
(Applaudissements)